hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
august 22nd 2022
what's going on how are you doing hey
how the
[__] are you doing
um i'm recording this on tuesday a day
late i apologize
i apologize to what it all i know uh i
didn't mean to offend anybody if
by claiming that tuesday is monday
i identify
as tuesday
tuesday identifies this monday
um
yeah i just had a [__] uh one of
those travel days yesterday
you know i was flying out of boston
logan
and um
you know i woke up in the morning badou
by deut and i saw the clouds
and it started to rain and i knew it was
gonna suck
um yeah [__]
just one of those days
um oh my god in your field like ripping
someone's head off
did anybody see that that [__] did i
talk about that yeah i already talked
about that
that [__] three-part documentary
um about woodstock 99
it's kind of an amazing thing where
nobody on any level from the bands
to uh
to the promoters
to the audience members nobody took
responsibility for what the [__]
happened there
i feel like all the people that snuck
into the event
in 1969 and 1994 should have apologized
the promoter should have apologized and
the bands should have said yeah maybe we
should have said hey everybody just
remember
look out for each other out there this
is about peace and love instead of just
[__] winding them up
even more
or my favorite was just everybody being
like yeah it just felt really [__] up
so we just got the [__] out of there
it felt like someone was gonna get hurt
so i left
um anyway
yeah it was um
yeah i just [__] woke up it was like
800 foot ceilings in like zero
visibility so i was like well i'm gonna
guess that we're gonna be delayed
um i had a nice little [__]
up and down flight right
and i'm not talking about the mile high
club i'm talking about a nice quick
flight all right just leave boston
go up
be in the air for an hour or so come
right down land
go through customs the easiest customs
ever canada oh how are you thanks for
showing no no they're not like that i'm
kidding
you know what's funny was kenny
the lady at the um
at security
um
is there anything better than like a
[__] beautiful chick that's got a
[__] gun you know you feel like
you're in a [__] spy movie
she was going uh
she's like
she goes you're working here i said yeah
he goes where you working
and kenny was like
uh
i don't know how to say a toscacia
bank
a rita
and she just [__] broke on this big
smile and she just goes scotia back
arena
kenny was like yeah
i don't know if i'm saying it right
um scotiabank
scotia
[__]
ariana
um
yeah we had like a [__] one o'clock
flight
and um
i don't know what it was no was it two
o'clock it was two o'clock
flight and i remember uh at some point
because i was you know i had the big gig
at fenway the night before was kind of
nodding off because i was sleeping at
one point they're like okay we're
finally gonna push away from the gate
uh we gotta
sit here on the tarmac they're giving us
a time of 4 18.
so we've already been sitting on the
plane for like two hours
just one of those deals and then we we
take off
and then when we landed because we were
so late there was no gate available and
we stayed on the ground for like another
[__] 45 minutes
um
[Music]
it basically took me from 12 noon to
about 8 o'clock at night to get from
boston to toronto
so i apologize for not um having the
podcast out earlier okay i know that was
just a bunch of excuses you're probably
thinking well hey man
like
why didn't you just record when you were
on the plane sitting there on the tarmac
why didn't you make use of your time
um you know maybe i could have done that
i don't know
but um
all i know is i'm [__] here in
toronto and i got two gigs that i'm very
i'm looking forward to
and uh
i'm finally in one city for more than
one night
so
i rented a drum kit i'm gonna go over to
the arena i'm gonna [__] play some
[__] gotta have a good time
and uh and with that
i've been kind of avoiding talking about
fenway because i don't even know how to
wrap my head around
that that even happened
um
i there's really i don't know there's no
[__] words to put into what that
experience was like
and
it was it was the biggest
crowd i'd ever been in front of it just
went on
forever
they put the stage
right in center field
which was the most perfect place
ever for a performer i think you know
that's the one thing that there's one my
major walk away
of that gig was if you are a center
fielder
in major league baseball you have the
best seat in the house
as far as
being able to take in a ballpark
you know it was just i was standing on
stage
and straight 12 noon it just said fenway
park all the way up at the top
and to my right was the green monster
where cattle fist hit the foul pole in
on my on my left was the pesky pole
and the crowd just went on forever and
then i just went into the stands and
just went all the way up into the night
and at the top it said fenway park and
it was the perfect evening
there was a nice breeze
and the fans
it was they went to a comedy show and
you could take them on a ride you could
bring them up you could bring them down
you know if i wanted to make it quiet
they would all be quiet i don't think i
got heckled
once i couldn't believe it i was
worried because
you know the show was supposed to start
at seven and we didn't go on until eight
because the lines were so long and
people had to like put their phones
into those yonder bags because
for whatever reason people really like
to hold comedians accountable
[Music]
for jokes
they for some reason really like to uh i
don't know what they just want to get
you in trouble and they spend all of
this
um energy doing that and
i think it's because they can get us and
there's a feeling of satisfaction where
if they sort of devoted that same sort
of energy
to like the pharmaceutical industry the
[__] warmongers
the you know the banks and all of that
they would just get nowhere and it would
be frustrating
where with us they can be like i can't
believe you said that
and then you know
you can at least get some attention i
don't know what it is so anyway
we had to make sure all the phones were
locked up which is i you know [__]
sucks
for people coming in
but i will tell you this it makes for a
way better show because people aren't
looking at their phones
and um
now that i think of it i did see one guy
looking down at his phone and i was
gonna make a joke about him checking the
scores on the west coast game and call
him a degenerate gambler
because i kind of forgot
that's what was happening anyway
so
you know we made like a little me we
filmed the show and we made like a
little mini documentary about me
starting out in boston and all of that
and one of the spots we went to was
fenway park
and
i went in there and lady gaga was
performing there
um that night
on the friday i think when we went to
film and i went in there and i was
[__] nervous i'm not gonna lie to you
i was nervous like
like oh you know this is a big one
don't [__] this up but when i went in
there
i don't know what it was it's just
because it is a small ballpark i mean
it's [__] huge for a comedy show but
like you you go in there and your
mindset is a baseball game
and
it's just a little place it's a little
intimate place it's why i think it's the
best ballpark by far
to go see a baseball game
and um
i went in there and i just had this
feeling i'm like this is going to be
[__] awesome and it's not going to be
hard it's actually going to be easy this
is going to be great
um
and i was walking around the park when
you're shooting a few things
and it just made me want to go to a
baseball game and
all of these memories were coming back
like
you know i was doing that when i was on
stage like you know i was joking i was
make sure you take it all in and i'm
like you know i can't take it all in i'm
not [__] sailing
but i kind of was able to
because
right in front of me it just said fenway
park
and then i had all of these memories and
i would be looking around going like i
saw a father and son get into a fight
right there
one of the funniest [__] things i
ever saw in my life
um
[Music]
it was just this dude i don't know his
son had some sort of issue
um like i don't know what
um
he kid wasn't drinking he had some sort
of mental issue going on and he was
[__] a big kid
and he was getting all amped up and his
dad was telling to calm down and it was
just like
and the kid just had enough of his dad
and they just [__] went in
and the kid connected first and then the
dad
threw a [__]
really
tight
efficient [__] body shot
which i thought came from a place of
love he didn't head hunt he [__] hit
him in the side this was the 80s
all right there wasn't a lot of help
for parents stressed out
with some six foot four kid that was you
know
i don't know
i don't i don't i still to this day
don't know what the issue there was
something going on there so you
i don't know
it was like funny just i don't know why
it was funny it was just funny because
it was like [__] sad and and
and the dad did what he had to do
and he [__] stopped it because it was
getting scary because he didn't know
what was going to happen i don't know
you know what
i look i don't i don't i just it's
something i saw
so i was thinking about that
and then i looked in the upper deck and
it's like that's the time i was drinking
and uh
i literally blacked out for three
innings and when i came to my shirt i
just had mustard all over it because i'd
eaten a hot dog
and when i came around like people was i
could just sense people sort of
looking at me in the side of their eye
and
so i just started talking to people you
know to let them know i was back and i
could just tell the way that they were
looking at me like some i did something
[__] up probably just them watching me
eating the hot dog like i mean mustard
was all over my [__] shirt
like i used it as a napkin or something
i don't know what i remember i was
wearing a blue
michigan wolverine t-shirt and said
michigan and yellow and then i just had
mustard all over the [__] thing
um
when i looked along the first baseline i
was thinking like that's where i went in
1986 when roger clemens was i believe
having his first cy young
uh season
and he'd already established himself as
this up-and-coming power
pitcher it was only his second year in
and i remember he had won like some
ridiculous amount of games in a row
we went to the game in like may or june
or something like that and he was
already like [__] like 10-0 or 12-0
or something and i went with my dad and
we had standing room only tickets along
the first baseline
the first time i went to a game was in
right field sat in the blue seats we saw
him play the tigers all of that [__]
dwight evans gunning people down from
[__] right field so i was able to
think all of that stuff
while um
i was doing my show but like um
you know we came down early we did like
a sound check
and i just remember thinking like this
is just gonna go great this is gonna be
great
right
and uh and then the [__] show started
and like
i don't know man i i
got really [__] like
antsy
it was weird it wasn't nervous i was
just like i just want to [__] go i
just got to get up there i just got to
get up there and do this and
i finally you know tony v was on stage
and i was standing in the tunnel that
center field garage all those years i
just saw like what the [__] is in there
you know i got to be in there right
and um
[Music]
i'm sorry guys there's just so much [__]
to try to remember first of all our
[__] green rooms
we had we had to walk into the red sox
dugout and go down that tunnel and all
of those years of watching them go down
there i thought you just went like
[__]
20 30 feet down and you just walked into
the clubhouse it's actually you walk in
to the left
is the batting cages
um
like exercise bikes and [__] like that
then you go straight you make a left you
go up like three stairs you make a right
go up another three stairs and then you
make
another right
and you walk to like you know like five
feet and then a left into like the
clubhouse
and i always thought you just walked
straight in and like there it was
and there was a flat screen tv for chris
sale to beat the [__] out of but it was
it wasn't like that and so
but anyway we were like beyond where
that was
just sitting in the dressing room was
funny when we were in the dressing room
i literally felt like i was sitting in
like a hotel
like waiting to uh do some corporate gig
and then finally i was just like
because it was taking so long with the
yonder bags kind of like me telling this
[__] story i was like i got to go out
and see what's going on so we went out
me and tony v we stood in the [__]
dugout and saw all of these people
coming in
and um
that's why i just got so [__] excited
like this is going to be [__]
unbelievable so anyway they finally
bring us around
tony v goes up i'm standing in a garage
area in center field and tony
immediately is getting laughs
it's going great and everything and i'm
basically tiptoeing towards the stage
and i come up the stage and had a little
lounge area with like couches and stuff
where the lovely nia was hanging out
and um
i was watching tony and i was just like
holy [__] this is just a comedy show
you know it's just in a baseball stadium
this is [__] bananas
and tony [__] crushed
and then he we did the uh we showed the
trailer to old dads people really liked
it
and then they brought me out and i came
out to aerosmith moving out
um one of my favorite [__] deep cuts
of aerosmith
um just sounded like a badass song you
know aerosmith is so connected to boston
it just seemed right to go out to that
and um
i don't know i went out on stage and for
some reason i just started making fun of
fenway park like the signage something
about draftkings i vaguely remember
doing that like you would just in any
other gig
and
i don't i don't know i just did my show
and i had a f
i still can't believe it happened
still can't believe it happened
everybody [__] laughed when they were
supposed to laugh i never got heckled
it was absolutely perfect and um
i felt like i was up there for only like
eight minutes i think i did like an hour
and 20 but i felt it felt like eight
minutes
and it was so [__] mind-blowing like
when i got off stage i had to ask people
for like 10 minutes was this good
was it all right did i do it and then
like it was fantastic it couldn't have
gone any better i was like
you sure
there was one part i thought i lost them
a little bit
i was like stammering
when i uh
when i got off stage and then we went up
you know the after party was up in right
field and
it was i joined it was lit when i said
thank you to people at the end of the
night i was i almost got choked up it
was so [__]
unbelievable and then in the end
me and tony was standing you know
waiting for it sort of to clear out in
the right field and people were walking
out
those exit in center field we were just
standing down there looking at him and a
few people saw me and tony
and they started yelling you know up to
us and everything you know we felt like
we won some election or something all
these people just yelling up and yelling
down to them
and i was watching all the people
walking out
and
i think just watching all of the people
walking out and them waving and saying
thanks and they had a good time was as
good a feeling as going up there
doing the show
and
then we had the after party
and we were sitting up
and basically it was like center field
is where we were like 10 rows up from
the ted williams seat
and we were just sitting there me and
all my friends like comedian friends
and my friends from high
school um
turned it into like a cigar bar
and after a while no one was talking
about the show
and we were just sitting around telling
funny stories
about growing up in like you know the
70s and 80s meet all my friends and like
you know my family was there and it was
just [__] it was an it was an amazing
night and uh
i i still can't believe it happened i
just want to thank everybody for coming
out
and um
it was it was [__] perfect
to the point
there was no hangover after the show
like um
you know i had yesterday off and i was
really worried
that like i was gonna be like
you know now i'm on the other side of it
now what
and
um it hasn't been like that at all it's
just like [__] that was unbelievable
i can't believe i got to do that
it couldn't have gone any better
and uh it's kind of [__] awesome that
it's not hanging over my head anymore
because i'm not gonna lie to you i
played that gig off the whole time
like what are you thinking i'm like and
i'm not really thinking about it i'm
just working on my act
you know how do you play a baseball
stadium well you know i guess we're
going to find out i just had all those
stupid [__]
but in my head it was like i don't know
i don't know how
that was
that was what was really going on so i
had to keep that at bay
by uh pretending to be overly relaxed
about the gig that's basically the truth
of it
um and now that it went well
i can admit to you that i was uh
you know i've obviously you know because
of my lack of athletic ability
i never [__] played a game seven in
my life i have no idea what that feels
like but i feel like i have felt the
closest thing
of like
my feeling was for [__] sakes why
can't the gig be right now why can't
they just just just get me out there
and if i'm gonna lose let's get it over
with and if i'm gonna win
let me just go out there and win and
let's [__] get this over with in the
back of my head i'm like going like no
no no no but don't look at it that way
you got to go out there and make sure
you take it in and all of that those all
of that stuff so
um
you know and then meanwhile
as this thing was hanging over my head i
was having as always you know i go back
i go back east to boston for like you
know
10 12 days
these last couple of years
and um i hit all of these places
you know from my childhood and i added a
new one i went to this pizza place in
[__] east boston that lived up to the
hype
all right i'm gonna give you guys the
name of it here at the risk of uh
you know
people getting mad like dude don't say
what the [__] spot is there's a place
if you ever go to boston uh
i hope i say right santarpio's
is where i went
um
you know there's all of these places
you know
uh linwood cafe cape cod pizza town spa
there's one that i still have to go to
called pleasant cafe in roslindale
and there are all these places they just
have these little personal size bar
pizzas
and that's sort of the boston style
pizza and it's funny like
i'm saying these places because you know
new yorkers will come up
and they'll be like hey you know i went
to boston the [__] pizza sucks
and it's like you know it doesn't you
just don't know where to go and the
reality is
is this is even in new york city the
reality with new york city is there's
only five or six places to go
however there's like 15 000 [__]
places to buy a
and
those five or six places in new york are
so [__] good
that the reputation is through the
ceiling and i know chicago's the same
way and i still don't know where to go
in chicago
you know everybody makes fun of it you
know
i remember john stewart said it's not
pizza it's [__] lasagna
uh the deep dish style but
there has to be a reason why
it's so popular there so i would imagine
in chicago that there's like five or six
places to go
so i went to this place santarpio's in
east boston
um
with club soda kenny and we were uh
because i was in
um saratoga springs new york the
saturday night i did fr i did
what did i do i did wednesday two shows
i did giggles
on friday i did knicks comedy stop which
is where i started my career 30 years
ago over 30 years ago
and then i went to
saratoga springs
on saturday and then
sunday night i did fenway so i was
beyond ready
um
so anyway before we went to saratoga
springs
this place east boston is right near
logan airport and we swung in there and
it ended up being like bigger sized
pizzas
and the crust was a lot thicker was a
different style it wasn't that classic
boston bar pizza but i'm gonna tell you
that anytime i go someplace new i always
get the the plain cheese the margarita
because i you know you can hide behind
your toppings i want to see
does your sauce have the [__] zing
you know with the cheese or whatever i
sound like [__] dave pornoy right now
um
and this place totally lived up to the
hype man it was [__]
delicious
and what i find with all great pizza
places is they understand that the job
of the cheese
is to [__] complement the sauce
that's where you go to the next level
all of these [__] idiots that think
the cheese
is the star of the show
you know
that's the starting quarterback you know
to the point they literally stick cheese
in the [__] crust
they don't know how to make pizza um
anybody else where you know the the the
tomato sauce the piece of sauce that
they put on and it's got that zing that
tang to it and then the cheese just
[__]
seamlessly blends into it i'm getting
hungry right now it was absolutely
[__] delicious and i've only known
like the south shore places
um
and when i was really young you know i i
lived up on the north shore before i
came down south
but um i was too young
you know i moved in like the mid 70s
down to the set my family moved down to
the south shore so i missed out on all
those places so anyway when you go up to
boston
you know go to those [__] places
and uh if you find some other ones let
me know about it um
yeah i'm trying to see i got a whole
bunch of
this marblehead house of pizza that's
another one i have to try out
i'm sort of determined
to go to every one of those little bars
pizza spots
you know over the years when i go to
boston and uh
so if you guys have like your spots
that's that's that's the really cool
thing i think about living in
massachusetts is every two to three
towns
you know has a place as a little bar
a little hole in the wall looking like a
dive bar type of place
that just makes a [__] outstanding
pizza that every everybody in the you
know the area like that's your spot
um that you go to so i got to do a
little bit of that
when i was at logan airport before you
know waiting on the delay
you know
i got to go it was a kelly's roast beef
that they have there there's also bill
and bob's roast beef i had kelly's roast
beef it was [__] delicious
um
although the bartender [__] annoyed
me when we showed up
you know we're standing there and it was
just like what do we do do we sit down
he's we can talk to him do we order from
you like he's like god do we order from
you and then i said yeah or do we have
like take like a picture do we take a
picture of this thing here you know
because they have that little [__]
barcode looking thing on the table and
then the guy just goes like
you know okay you guys are asking me two
different things right now
he does one of those things and i was
just like
i can't remember what i said to him i
said yeah we're trying to [__] test
your memory you douche i [__] i think
there was somebody else earlier that day
oh i know we went through [__] tsa
and for whatever reason i wasn't uh
you know pre-checked i thought it was i
always am i walked by the lady i showed
him my ticket whatever and then there
was this [__] guy at the tsa thing
that he was one of those sing-songy
[__]
you know what i mean where he'd be like
you don't have the right idea no the
right id or whatever blah blah blah he
was like doing that but it was like
totally passive aggressive over the top
everything was like go [__] yourself
underneath it i got up there and
like
the way he said that you're not tsa
pre-check
i was looking at him like is this guy
[__] with me
like why would you say that in that
happy tone
like hey
you're gonna have to go to the back of
another line like
like i just want a car on the price is
right so i was looking at him like going
like
all right is he just [__] with me
does he know i'm a comedian so he's
trying to break my balls and i just sort
of sat there
and then i realized he was serious i was
just like
okay all right no worries and i just
kind of went over to the other line and
then i was standing there
thinking about it i was like
i don't know maybe i'm wrong but was it
me or was that guy like really thrilled
to tell us to get the [__] out of that
line
um
so maybe that's what it was then i go to
the [__] roast beef gun he's like
okay you guys were asking me two
different things right now
like shut the [__] up
we asked you two really simple things
how the [__] do we order a [__]
sandwich here with this new buck rogers
technology where i just point my phone
at the thing i don't take a picture
because i always end up taking a picture
of the [__] thing
that actually happened
earlier in that week when we were
[__] calling up to make sure that we
had i was trying a different pizza place
and we're like you have just calling
over just making sure you have a record
of our order and the guy goes i don't
it's like well we ordered online
and the guy's like well i don't have
record of it
and it's like uh
what can we just order through you
and he's like uh actually no you cannot
uh we have a we have a company that
handles all our orders it was like
you're at the place
you speak english we speak english can
we just order two [__] pieces through
you
and he's like
oh absolutely absolutely you can't it's
like well that's what the [__] was
i don't know what the [__] that was
i have a problem
can you help me no i cannot
like who says it like that
don't you usually just go you know
unfortunately i can't i know this is a
crazy system i don't own the business
this is the way they run it it makes no
sense to me i apologize you know
and no i cannot
i'm hanging from a cliff i got two
fingers left is there any way you can
help me up i cannot help you up
unfortunately you gotta with your hand
that's dangling
from the cliff can you reach into your
pocket and get out your phone and call
the park ranger
we outsource helping people falling from
a clip
um
anyway
anyway i don't know maybe this is just
the [__]
[__]
i was holding in to do it you know so i
wouldn't freak out and do the gig so i
know i just babbled for a half an hour
uh people i did stand stand up at fenway
park
in front of almost [__] 40 000 people
was like 38 or 39 000 people it was the
biggest [__] crowd i've ever been it
just went on for [__] ever and they
were all amazing oh and i also forgot
you know it was my 35th year uh high
school reunion and uh there was a bunch
of people i went to high school with
were hanging in a bar that was inside of
fenway park somehow i don't know how
that works
and the security guy took me up through
the back way and i walked in through the
back door into the crowd literally right
into my high school reunion and i got to
see like you know i could only do it for
a minute because it was uh i had to do
the show and it was you know super
[__] loud and it wasn't just
the class of 87 there it was
it was just you know a bunch of people
also going to the show so i was only
able to be in there for like 10 minutes
but i got to see like 20 or 30 people
that um
you know some of whom i you know i don't
think i had seen since i [__]
we graduated man and it was just great
seeing all of them i had a really cool
graduation graduation class like i had a
real
mellow
grade that like to party
and a bunch of funny [__] people in
there and uh
i got to see a good you know i feel like
20 or 30 of them before i dip back out
again it was kind of like the perfect
night all right i'm done babbling
all right i know that you guys are
probably rolling your eyes at this point
but it was [__]
um it was an experience that i will
never ever ever forget so thank you to
everybody and with that let's do some
reads here all right simply safe
everyone
here's a question
is there anything that matters more than
the safety of you and your loved ones
um
yeah of course not
you know i mean you don't be so selfish
maybe you could say world peace
and every everybody having safety but
you know the way the game is set up and
how you know everybody's chasing the
dollar at the end of the day you got to
go self-preservation
and isn't it nice that a company
understands capitalism
and they realize that it's about the
safety of you
and the people you love and everybody
else can go [__] themselves so isn't it
strange that many home security
companies don't act that way
this is why i use and trust simply safe
home security their advanced security
technology helps me sleep at night
and they always put me in my family
safety first here's why i love it with
24 7 professional monitoring simply safe
agents call you the moment a threat is
detected and dispatch police or first
responders in an emergency
you know i take issue with first
responders all right you're not a first
responder i am
i'm the guy that hears the axe murderer
i respond first and pick up my phone and
say i think there's someone in my house
even if you're not home or can't be
reached simply safe
we'll [__] dispatch people i guess i
don't know simply safe monitoring agents
truly care about your well-being
and are highly trained to keep you calm
and safe during stressful situations
staying online with you until help
arrives
that has to be an intense job simply
saves customer first policy make sure
you're taken care of with affordable
plans starting at less than a dollar a
day and no long-term contract or hidden
fees because feeling safe at home
shouldn't break the bank customize the
perfect system for your home in just a
few minutes at
simplisafe.com go today and claim a free
indoor security camera plus twenty
percent off
with interactive monitoring go to simply
safe dot com slash bur that's s i m p l
i
s a f e
dot com slash
here's another thing i was thinking
before i go this is just gonna all be
about doing
the fenway gig
i was thinking about all the gigs that i
did
that led up there i remember
when i was living in new york
you know after i did stand up for three
and a half years i moved down to new
york and then i came back
and i headlined spaghetti freddies
which to me is one of the worst names
ever
for a [__] restaurant there's just
something about it rhyming
it's just silly it just doesn't make me
feel like you're going to take anything
seriously uh spaghetti freddy like
they're just gonna [__] you know
reach into the pot with a big spoon
swirl it around and then pull out a
bunch of spaghetti and then just [__]
throat you throw it like hang onto the
spoon and just
zing it across the room as you have
[__] spaghetti
so i played the basement of spaghetti
freddy's on route 1 in norwood right
next to that golfing driving range and
there was a howard johnson's
across the parking lot and i did [__]
stand up there too
over the years i think if you go up
route one
at some point every restaurant had an
open mic
or something like that or nick's comedy
stop
like next comedy stop i remember had um
oh [__] sorry tired here next comedy
stop
had um
like these satellite rooms they had
their downtown main room and then they
they would have them like in chinese
restaurants
or there was like this [__] like
nightclub ballroom looking place out on
framingham on route 9. there was one in
randolph's like the holiday inn there
was the maui
in uh
brockton mass with the highest [__]
stage ever it was like he was standing
on top of a refrigerator box except it
was solid
i remember that you were way up in the
air
on this little [__] postage stamp
of a stage for some [__] reason like
like your feet were like five feet above
the heads of the people sitting down on
the front row i don't know why and the
room wasn't even that big you just they
just had you up there
um
i don't know what i felt like like uh
like you were in superman talking to uh
lauren green or some [__]
um anyway
the uh
and then they had the the kowloon in
saugus
another chinese restaurant
just all of those gigs came back but i
remember when i did spaghetti freddies
uh
they had a function room down in the
basement
so are you on in here i [__] went uh
and i when i tell you dude like
there was like eight people in the crowd
there was like and i knew like six of
them
it was like
you know my family members came out and
a couple of their friends
and then there was like a two top of
strangers
and i'm trying to play this
[__] gig by just looking over
everybody's head because i actually am
related to 80 of the crowd
and i still somehow had like a decent
set
but i just remember
um
i just remember being really embarrassed
i didn't wait i don't even think it was
embarrassing at that point in my career
because i wasn't selling any tickets
i think that the victory was
as shitty as this gig is
i am headlining it
i've worked my way up to headlining the
basement of a spaghetti freddies in
norwood massachusetts so i think i on
some level
i felt like my career was still moving
forward
while at the same time
i was also thinking like are you really
headlining on a gig like this or you
more just sort of going on last
and um
i still think i had an okay set
and uh
i don't know yeah there was just a lot
of those moments
that i guess should have been like
humiliating enough
to make you want to think about doing
another job but like if you love doing
stand-up that never enters your head
you just sort of look them it's just
funny stores
to tell your friends yeah
i played a place called spaghetti
freddies
basically in front of my family members
and a couple people i went to high
school with
and this random couple
oh my god
i just remember too like the [__]
i remember across the parking lot
between the driving range between the
two places was a driving range and that
other place was the howard johnson's and
i remember playing the lounge area
and it actually ended up being actually
killed
it was a crowded bar and no one was
[__] really listening and i went up
there and i improv something that got
people to pay attention and i was
actually able to get on a little bit of
a roll and did like five
minutes and
i got off stage and there was this
comedian greg carey who i had not seen
in like 20 years who showed up to my gig
in queens new york
with tommy yamato
and uh it was so great to see him
another guy who was always nice to me
just like tony v
and would help you out and everything um
was not
you know
i'm not you know some of the
just it was just when i started
in stand-up
stand-up was in a nosedive it was like
in a free fall coming out of the 80s
where all of a sudden
people just didn't want to go out to
comedy clubs anymore and it was it was
like a housing bubble except with stand
up and all of these rooms were
collapsing and the work was
not really drying up as much as it was
coming
back down
to um
like the level that it should have been
at and a lot of people were getting
squeezed out so there was a lot of
bitter headliners and uh
greg carey and tony v were never like
that because they were both funny guys
so they weren't like nervous they
they knew that they were gonna be fine i
guess i don't know why they're just good
people i have no idea
so anyway um
yeah i'm [__] bombing there i'm just
gonna be telling stories the whole
[__] time all of my early day gigs
like route one to me is an amazing
like highway because
when i'm on the north shore
that's all like my childhood
when i was really really
young and some of the places that i
played
not just the kowloon or giggles if you
kept going up north
i remember
i remember allen the monkeys
which was uh
had dane cook it was a sketch group
think they'd all do stand up and then
they do sketch in the end it was dane
cook bobby kelly
aldel benny
and um
oh my god i'm old what was the last
kid's name
it'll come to me um
and i opened for them they booked
themselves in like this [__] elks
club
or some [__] like that
because they'd won the bcn comedy riot
at stitches
and they were trying to
headline their own show whatever and
like we were all young
and we didn't know how to promote [__]
and there was like [__] like five
people there
and
i remember all of us we were just like
they were like embarrassed but they were
also like laughing and i was laughing
and it was kind of this fun moment
because
we were all so young
and it felt cool to me to be doing their
gig because everybody else's gig that i
was doing had been doing it like 20
years and they were like
legends of boston comedy and we were
just a bunch of young punks and as much
as
nobody showed up it was still i was
working
you know a show from these people that
were part of my graduating class
and uh long story short whatever it was
just
it was comedy death but like we all
supported each other and laughed at each
other's jokes
um
yeah all the way up there rob steen used
to have gigs up there all of these guys
i just remembered all of these [__]
gigs
all the way up to like
i remember working bars in like revere
um
remember dick dougherty's had like rooms
all over the place like [__] drake it
and danvers and
all of these [__] places over the
years and i think uh
i don't know just driving around
waiting for this [__] giant gig i
just all of those memories came back it
was just a really really cool time so i
apologized on being old billy reminisce
here
um i don't feel like i've been even
remotely funny on this one let's um
let's get to some of your questions
maybe we can get to some comedy here
um
all right what do we got here
uh
all right
boston bill i'm in boston for the first
time to see your show i think the
stereotypes are dead on and dead wrong
lots of meat heads absolutely
i am a proud meathead i always always i
was joking with somebody who was talking
about how massachusetts has the boston
area has some of the great universities
in the country
you know harvard mit
and even like boston university and like
but barely anybody from massachusetts
goes there we have a bunch of like free
free agents smart kids from around the
world
that come in there and um
you know as much as you know we liked
goodwill hunting
we all knew that there was really no
smart kid
that came from a broken home that could
figure out a math problem that had like
sentences and triangles in it you know i
mean that's just next level [__] math
or whatever and no one ever said do you
like apples okay other than that it's a
great [__] movie
um lots of meatheads but they seem oddly
smart
and
are always very helpful
i was trying to talk to someone
stupid uh for the experience
well aren't you a [__] [__] you
just went up there and you were trying
to talk to somebody dumb so you could
just have an experience of talking to
somebody's stump
dumb i talked to a guy dropping lots of
r's and other various letters for a few
minutes and he was really intelligent
but tell me why is masshole a thing
um
well part of it is just a simple thing
that if you travel what you'll quickly
realize
is that
you know especially as a comedian if
you're having a bad set
and you need a laugh and you don't have
a local reference
to identify with the people just make
fun of whatever state the state you're
in borders
and you'll get a laugh
like if you're in wisconsin you make fun
of minnesota or illinois
right
if you're in iowa you make fun of
illinois but what's north of that
minnesota
if you're in north dakota you make fun
of south dakota or montana if you're in
montana you make fun of idaho you get
the deal that's all you do because so
like mass hole comes from
you know maine vermont
new hampshire connecticut rhode island
in new york i think that that's where it
all comes from
basically maine doesn't border
massachusetts but you can drive through
just the bottom corner
of new hampshire and you're out of
massachusetts and into maine within like
[__] half an hour and
i just think uh
i don't know
we go up
to different states well you know what
we go up to [__] lake winnipesaukee
or sugarloaf mountain skiing or [__]
you know
getting drunk on a boat and we act like
a bunch of [__] [__] probably i
don't know
i grew up in massachusetts so i have
no idea
where that comes from but like um
[Music]
i will tell you
there is a brilliance to the meatheads
that are in massachusetts and um
i find my new york friends
begrudgingly have to admit
how funny
the average person is that walks around
boston they're just like
i i can't explain it i mean i don't know
if that's still like a thing but it was
when i was growing up with it was so
many [__] people
that are a thousand times funnier than i
will ever be
and i'm not being humble i'm being dead
serious like they [__] they're way
funnier than i'll ever be but they don't
even know that they're being funny
they're literally just living their
lives and i've always said like some
people tell the story that's me and some
people are the story
and uh the people that are the story are
like
i don't know what the deal is like they
just
the [__] that they say and the stuff
that they do
like um
they're just sort of like fearless
like just the kind of people that would
literally
you know
i don't know like the amount of fights i
walked away from because it's like i
don't want to get the [__] kicked out of
me and then also i'm not fighting you
here
i'm not fighting you i'm not going to
get into a fist fight in the men's
clothing department at jordan marsh i'm
not doing that but other people would
and they it would never dawn under them
how [__] hilarious it was to get into
a fist fight
at an anchor store at a mall
you know or at a sporting event
or in a [__] you know a line waiting
for like pizza or something like that
because they were just wired
differently
you know and like
you know i went to a patriots game one
time like a [__] pre-season game and
two of my buddies went to down to get a
beer and when they came back
one of my buddies was laughing his ass
off and my other buddy he is [__] the
collar of his shirt he had a t-shirt on
was completely ripped
and he had a bloody lip
and the other guy was laughing his ass
off because
he like started the fight
and the guy whatever he said
this dude thought my other buddy said it
and suckered my buddy and then my buddy
won the fight and then they were going
to get kicked out
and somebody else said no no no no they
didn't start it the other guy started it
and the security guards just believed
them
so they let you stay there's no [__]
i think i just told this i can't
remember my head's spinning i might have
told this story a few podcasts ago
but like
i mean they let him go back to his seat
with his shirt ripped and a like an
actively bleeding lip like they would
never let you do like everybody would be
gone there's a [__] judge
in a [__] courthouse at half of these
goddamn ballparks it was just sort of
like uh
i don't know what it was it was just a a
i i don't know it's just a very uh
i don't know what the word is it was
just [__] weird there was just always
fights
always something stupid going on always
somebody trying to steal something that
was so ridiculously big and awkward and
that they would get caught and then they
had to go to court
people forever had [__] broken hands
from getting into fights
and then they would just show up to work
with the broken hand and a [__] black
eye
drinking a dunkin donuts coffee
and uh
and you'd be like do what happened yeah
you know i got a [__] fight you know
standing outside a leech me i was trying
to put a lamp in the back of my mom's
station wagon i see this guy he's
[__] eyeballing me i was like buddy
if you're gonna [__] stare at me you
could at least [__] help me out or
why don't you just [__] take that
look somewhere else so next thing you
know we're rolling around on the [__]
ground like that was like
and they're telling the story and like
they're not trying to be funny they're
just saying what the [__] happened so
i don't know and somewhere in that
be i don't know i think the masshole
thing came about i don't know
all right uh experts and eggs
oh this is a [__] cool email here
actually you know i read this one before
the podcast here dear bill i'm with you
on the expert's problems i'm a lab
scientist with 35 years of experience
i've worked with not for the fda
i've consulted for drug companies and
food companies and over a half dozen
different concentrations
i'm what you would call an expert but
most of the people in my field should
really be called know-it-alls
um
[Music]
a lot of these experts often change side
sides and their recommendations
routinely
follow the interest of who's writing the
check i gotta be honest with you i don't
know how the [__] people live their
lives like that
that you would literally change your
opinion on something because you now
work for somebody like
you know people are giving this food to
their kids
how could you knowingly say something
wrong or not even give a [__] about what
you were saying
the almighty dollar uh science requires
questions real science welcomes
questions
answers them gladly and says we don't
know when something is unknown
yeah that's why science is way more
interesting to me than religion
like what do they always say in religion
like that's not for us to know but for
him to say and you'll find out when you
die can we have some more money please
um
[Music]
how refreshing would it be in like
religion
hey father what happens when you croak
uh you know what i don't know
i have no idea i have no idea if you go
to a happy place if you're just dead
if you get punished for being bad i have
no [__] idea
you know i don't you know
i don't get any of that [__] i don't get
anything about religion i don't get the
whole fact that like what if you
are a good person and then something so
[__] horrible happens to you as a kid
you end up being [__] up and then you
just live a [__] up life
and then what you go to hell for the
rest of your life
because of something that happened to
you when you were a kid it just doesn't
make any [__] sense and it's just
like why
do does bad things hap why do bad things
happen to children
why do they see domestic violence
why do they get beaten why do they get
molested why does all of that [__]
happen and then like there's no help for
those kids
and then they go out into the [__]
world
and you know
then they start acting like an [__]
and then you die and then god's mad at
you when he made the [__] child
molester to begin with but then he
blames and says oh no it was the devil
it was the devil and you listen to the
devil you [__] so-and-so so now i'm
gonna burn you forever i mean it doesn't
make any sense as opposed to science
which goes like okay
this is the x factor this is the answer
we're going to try to go back to the
words to the question or here's the
question and we're going to try to work
our way out
to the answer and all of this [__] has
to [__] check out and when it all
checks out then they have the answer but
then they're also still open to the fact
that in the future they might realize
that the way that they got to the answer
there was some fly in that ointment and
that needs to be adjusted
so that they they can come to the new
right answer
right
i don't know anyway when all of a sudden
eggs were considered bad for you okay so
people who didn't hear the other podcast
i was like in my lifetime eggs have been
good for you bad for you
good for you
and now i feel like they're starting to
come back around where i'm starting to
hear some chatter that they might be bad
again so this person says when all of a
sudden eggs were considered bad for you
there was little push back by academics
who should have been questioning why
suddenly the egg was bad
where were the studies and tests well
there were very few and they
cherry-picked the information to say
choleste the cholesterol was bad but
science had known about different types
of cholesterols and eggs shouldn't have
been considered a problem so basically
they were good cholesterol people ate
eggs thousands of years before all the
heart diseases were as prevalent as they
are now and of course we found out that
the sugar industry paid off groups like
the fda to recommend low-fat high-carb
diets can you imagine
working for the [__] fda
and they come in there with that
suitcase full of cash and then you go
out there and [__] send out all this
misinformation that causes people to
have [__] heart disease it's
unfucking believable why aren't they
held accountable
who is in the fda
who are these people you have no [__]
idea
i guess the fda needs to start putting
out [__] food specials
so people can hold them accountable um
is it wise to be skeptical of experts in
a lot of sponsored fields
uh oh it is wise to be skeptical of air
quote experts in a lot of sponsored
fields experts are increasingly losing
their expertise
there's a great video of a lifelong
environmentalist farmer slash old timer
who talks about dealing with young
experts who don't go into the field or
believe
anything unless it's in a book
that's been peer reviewed i.e signed off
on by those in charge all right so i'll
give you the name of this thing
um
alan savory savory
a-l-l-e-n-s-a
what is science
um
check out that one out if you can and
i'll tell you one of the worst things is
that they're gonna make mushrooms
that help me so much just on two trips
uh that those things will eventually
become legal in the [__]
pharmaceutical industry i guarantee you
will immediately one of the first things
they'll do so it tastes better is
they're gonna put [__] sugar in it
like they do with [__] those goddamn
gummies and all of that stuff like like
i don't know [__]
about science and all that but i can
tell you right now
weed is i'm
since it's become legal is probably way
more worse for you than it was back in
the day when you had to smoke an entire
bag just to feel a little [__] up
um
and from what i heard the other day like
all modern medicines
are part of the the mushroom coaching
tree and that they're going to go in and
for profit [__] that up and make
taking mushrooms now have side effects
that need to be treated by their [__]
drugs it's so [__] evil
and none of them get held accountable
and they're literally killing people and
[__] with
nature
you know the fact that a group of
[__] people can go out and like
change
like have biochemically engineered food
they're literally [__] with the food
supply
um
it's a terrorist act i believe and
nothing happens to them
um anyway [__] up story yo bill thrill
um my brother and i are both vets and we
have a running joke about how poorly
vets are treated
uh another thing that's nobody is held
accountable for i hate to make light of
a [__] up situation but it gets us
through exactly
it's called gallows humor
you know
you're making a joke not because you
don't care it's because you do care and
you don't want to feel the pain and for
some reason these [__] literal
larry's out there don't understand that
how can you joke about something like
that because it's painful you [__]
[__] that's what comedy is
or can be
it's like a [__] topical anesthetic
for your feelings so you don't actually
feel the [__] that [__] pain and
you're a [__] because you're sitting
just stating the obvious
what just happened is sad
thank you
um anyway i just this person says i just
read a crazy story about a vet in canada
who called the ptsd hotline
um i can't remember what the
post-traumatic stress
i don't know what um anyway the person
he spoke with didn't give him guidance
or direct him to mental health options
get this instead they offered him
medically assisted death
jesus christ the guy said i laughed my
ass off at the absurdity of this and my
heart went out to the vet i completely
understand that reaction
because what else are you gonna do
what else are you gonna do
um i remember reading in that uh that
book johnny carson's lawyer wrote
and just how mean and cold his mother
was and any time johnny would try to do
something nice for her to try to
get the loving
emotion from his mom that he so wanted
she would be even colder when he would
try to get that from her and she would
be so [__] mean all he could do is
just then retell the story to his lawyer
and then he would just start laughing
because what the [__] else are you gonna
do
um
yeah so you hear something like that you
know you love your buddies
you have a bond
you served
and the fact that someone say that is
just so [__]
horrible what else are you gonna do
other than laugh
so anyways he said i laughed my ass off
at the absurdity of this and my heart
went out to the vet i honestly think
that they should have a public execution
of the person who took that man's call
the only way to protect the sanctity of
life would be to publicly murder the
person who disrespected it right bill so
see that
underneath that joke there's in those
last two sentences
is his real emotions
about how much
the person cares and then there's the
anger underneath it
um that was actually a great lesson in
comedy that whole how comedy can work um
so he has to laugh at it to to
keep it bay
the pain that then turns into murderous
[__] thoughts
um i relate to that on obviously much
lesser level
um
i can't believe someone did that
well how about you know we can't solve
the problem how about we help you kill
yourself jesus christ
all right let's hope this one's a little
more happier than that all right old
school home remedies all right
hi bill i know it's been a while since
you talked about home remedies from
older generations i'd like to submit
something my my grandmother swore by she
would tell us grandma grandchildren to
never ever swallow bad spit
basic saliva was okay for this woman but
if you have what she would call
what we would call these days as a
loogie
yeah if you got phlegm and all that she
worked in the yard a lot
with her plants and in her garden
constantly spitting never had allergies
and she lived to be 98.
she claimed that everything we cough up
our hack up was all the stuff that
caused disease as i approached my
mid-30s i'm more inclined to believe she
was onto something keep spitting bill
love you and love the podcast
um all right that is the podcast i
apologize if uh for being late and also
that i babbled
um
about
fenway park i still cannot believe i
just can't believe that that happened
and
um i am i i don't know that how long
it's going to take for me to actually
process it because if the crowd was so
[__] big and i had to make sure that
i didn't lose them but like i'll tell
you in the end when i said good night
and everybody stood up like
i will never ever forget that it was
[__] unbelievable so
there you go here's your inspiration for
the week all right you can suck at
reading out loud and you can suck at
math and you can go to summer school
and uh but if you follow your hat and
you go where you're supposed to go
you're gonna be just fine in life so
don't let anybody scare the [__] out of
you you're gonna be fine all right
that is all
and with that go [__] yourselves
football season is coming
and so are the tampa bay devil rays
there are only eight games out
i'm just sitting there right now i'm
like the old guy muppet on the muppet
show just [__] i this is my my worst
thing
i'm i'm going to get out of this i'm not
going to sit here and just root for the
yankees to lose
i think that's just a really [__]
[__] sports fan thing to do even
though i know all the yankee fans would
do that
i just think it's bad karma and all of
that
um
the red sox are out of it at this point
i think barring an amazing comeback i'm
still gonna watch them but i'm also
going to root for aaron judge to break
roger maris's
steroid free home run record i really
hope he gets it
um so that's it go [__] yourselves and
i'll check in on you on thursday